elle accueillera les jeux olympiques de
paris 2024 mais avant la colline
d'elancourt devra être aménagé plus de
350 ils en ont participé ces derniers
mois à des concertations avant la
validation du projet par l'agglomération
objectif transmettre leurs
interrogations leurs inquiétudes et
apporter de nouvelles idées nous allons
ensuite reçus m le résultat des études à
un vote qui serait deux fois ci à une
prise de position qui sera électronique
pour la population qui aura lieu pendant
tout le printemps 2022 à nouveau nous
allons pouvoir débriefer l'ensemble des
interventions avant la fermeture du site
pour travaux en 2023 ces discussions ont
permis de confirmer les impératifs en
vue de la transformation et ce qu'ont
donné les différentes études totalisé et
le retour des habitants bien c'est la
même la même orientation la volonté de
conserver un parc ouvert à la population
vers vertueux est donc un maximum
d'efforts a été émis a été confirmée par
les résultats des études de fait auprès
de la population de la volonté de
densifier encore la protection de
l'environnement c'est pourquoi les ce
qu'on appelle la compensation écologique
sur ce site sur un certainement une des
composants station écologique les plus
exemplaires que de tout paris 2024 autre
interrogation l'héritage après les jeux
et comment mettre en relief le futur
espace sportif
le site a été pensé pour pouvoir une
fois que les jeux olympiques sont
terminés donc qu'il soit ouvert au
public mais également que l'ensemble des
infrastructures invisible tout ce qui
permet techniquement de pouvoir très
rapidement réinstaller un lieu d'accueil
des preuves de vtt soit présent tout ce
qui est passage des câbles tout ce qui
est technique etc mais ce sera
absolument invisible permettront demain
de pouvoir bien positionné à nouveau
très rapidement un village pour un
week-end de vtt et pourquoi pas à
nouveau accueillir par exemple les
championnats du monde de vtt en plus du
vtt à elancourt les yvelines
accueilleront le bmx le cyclisme sur
piste et sur route le pentathlon moderne
le golf et les sports équestres cette
épreuve olympique dont celle d'elancourt
sous l'oeil de la grande dame de fer